an ongoing threat to the country the
words of the judge who sentenced the
founder of the right-wing militia group
The Oath Keepers to 18 years in jail
Stuart Rhodes a former paratrooper was
convicted of seditious conspiracy
essentially trying to overthrow the
government by firing up those who staged
The Assault on the capital on January 6
2021 they were trying to stop the
certification of Joe Biden as president
he claimed in court he was a political
prisoner a position rejected by the
judge there's no way that he was the
leader of the director of what happened
on January 6th he was just a convenient
Target The Oath Keepers were a
convenient Target the doj looked at them
and said oh here's a skate here are the
scapegoats of what happened on January
6th Rhodes and his followers dressed in
combat style gears to confer John the
capital while he never entered he was in
constant contact with those in sight
he'd stashed weapons in nearby hotels
and prosecutors said he was ready to use
them to force Congress to back Donald
Trump the defense argued roads should be
essentially free today having spent 16
months sin present but the judge clearly
felt that the offenses needed a much
stiffer sentence and 18 years is the
longest jail term handed to anyone
convicted of offenses from January the
6th Rhodes claim of being a political
prisoner Echoes the words of some
Republican members of Congress they have
defended those charged and convicted of
offenses from January the 6th and Donald
Trump running for re-election as U.S
president has promised pardons for all
convicted if he wins
more than one thousand people have been
charged with offenses surrounding
January the 6th 2021 Rogers to appeal
the conviction and the length of his
deal term Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
Washington